en prenant l'exemple des liens de
parenté pourtant tellement utile à
préciser dans les textes officiels
nous pourrions citer bien des cas où
l'arbre généalogique devient un buisson
très évidente
alors pour ne pas laisser les petits
neveux grimper dans les branches
ascendante ou encore le puîné appelé
germaine toutes ses proches cousines
gérard pas bio a recueilli ces quelques
précisions dans les rues piétonnes père
putatif même tentative je vous dirais je
vous dirais le maire qui fait mauvaise
vie mais j'ai un père putatif et bien
joué c'est pareil pour loeb quoi c'est à
dire c'est un père qui fait mauvaise
nuit
un géniteur qu'est ce que c'est et bien
c'est comme le hashtag et puis par
exemple charge la définition du géniteur
qu'est ce que c'est c'est ce qui fait
défini pourquoi dit-on la branche
cadette par exemple un site une famille
moins fortunés et c'est ça et pourquoi
dit-on cadette
qui a des dettes qui a des dettes plus
que l'autre famille issu de germain
qu'est ce que ça signifie ici germain
c'est côté germanique basse est le fils
d'un allemand qu'appelle-t-on la voie du
sang alors en compte je parle au repos
jusqu'à 24 reconnaître la voix du sang
le mot devenu coeur et un multiple du
par 3 et si ça dépasse 80 82
le
personne normale ajout paraît normal là
vous connaissez vous entendez ma voix du
sang là il faut que vous touchez le
pouls pour connaître ma voix du sang le
battement du coeur et aux doigts dit
paul le coup et vous comptez jusqu'à 30
et a multiplié par trois si je vous dis
un par un dans une famille comment vous
voyez ça un parent d'un parent c'est le
père la mère le fils la fille toute la
famille c'est les uns derrière les
autres en termes de design à la suite
des autres à la queue leu leu
avez-vous les cousines germaines non
monsieur régis pas de couches de
germaine s'appellera carmen et saper
pire est il si ça mes cousines
qu'appelle-t-on les ascendants
descendants pour baiser les personnes
qui n'ont pas de dents
personnes qui n'ont pas de dents c'est
quoi par rapport à vous par exemple les
acides et d'armes est sympa c'est passé
pas pu dire déjà sans nom par rapport à
vous c'est quoi les grands-pères et
grands-mères sans nom et non comme nos
grands pères présence d'une grand-mère
main qui a pris dedans les ascendants
qu'appelle-t-on le puîné c'est le car le
puits fini de creuser et que l'on peut
se servir de l'eau voyez-vous ce qu'on
appelle un mariage consanguin madame
c'est un mariage
dire il faut le dire aux rêveries un
mariage consanguin un mariage content
parce qu'il ya pas de gagnage comment
vous m'avez dit content parce qu'il n'y
a pas de gain de gains c'est à dire pèse
d'argent il pourrait y en avoir alors dû
du gain bah si c'est un mariage
autrement autrement un mariage d'argent
alors à l'heure où les consanguins parce
que parce que il est con sans gain un
mariage d'amour en quelque sorte mariage
qui n'a pas de gain c'est à dire que n'a
pas tu n'as pas d'argent
un mariage d'amour ben oui
mais ça vous paraît qu'on vous pas
tellement
[Musique]